good morning Lyle's welcome back to the
morning toast happy Thursday it is our
final show of the week before we head
off for Thanksgiving break and you know
what like I'm sorry but the show
couldn't come soon enough I'm at my I'm
at my balm strings end oh is that a
phrase it is now I guess you didn't
listen to my episode with time your ad
where like I was talking about how I
have like a long I couldn't think of the
word it was fused yeah Shuang straight
yeah I've a long bomb string but a big
bomb you got it yes so you like your
patients as long but once it's thin I'm
punching checkout machines just like a
few inches away from that status that's
a good combo like I have a very short
fuse and a very big bomb it's like you
set me off like one thing sets me off
and I'm out of control like so I guess
that's better I mean yeah it's just like
trying times you guys I don't know I'm
so I just really need a vacation I'm
really looking forward to some QT with
the family yeah I'm very much looking
forward to QT with the family so sad
that where we're going we can't bring
Theo
so Theo's gonna be at his in-laws which
honestly he likes his in-laws better
than me I think like when he's at my
house he thinks he's on vacation like
when he goes back to Ben's parents he's
like finally I'm home like yeah Ben's
mom is just like such a good caretaker
and I'm just like not so it's like sad
and I feel like when Theo is with like
Ben's mom and our family together when
we're all together he's like how do
these people know each other it's like
you're camp friends your school friends
and like your college friends all in one
room yes his birthday party yeah um we
went to the loo combs concert last night
at the iHeartRadio Theatre yeah the PC
Richards it was you see Richards it was
a livestream that like that a very small
audience foreign snitch like somehow
been tangled us some tickets and it was
so good it was so good it was quite
intimately just for like industry
insiders like us and like huge fans yeah
you know I used to work at I heard so I
can actually tell you exactly what that
is because one time when I worked there
they had like internal contests you put
a lottery you could because there's not
space for that many people in the
theater so not all the employees can go
but like you can win the ticket so I
once won Carrie Underwood tickets and I
went with snitch it was really exciting
there were some celebs there Bobby bones
was there he was hosting the actual
livestream like doing a human eyes and
it was live for radio so it's like a
radio show it's a live stream it's like
good interview for bigwigs and I think
like buyers you know it's presented by
State Farm it's really just like all
about the industry yeah and then a
couple like fans got to come too because
they wouldn't tickets on c100 not ship
them and you know through the snitch we
worked for iHeartRadio now and I just
want to say here some celebs who I saw I
saw Bobby bones I saw one of the
Impractical Jokers
I want to say his name is hey Merv
someone posted it in the toasters cuz
the pack of snitches head was on his
story look he's just a loot combs then
it's just so interesting like that's
just people who come because they want a
continent not like they're not paid to
come like they just wanted to come like
they were in New York oh and the other
big group of people that were in the
audience for toasters oh it was toasty
affair bigwigs toasters and the
practical joker yeah so many toasters
and we need to give a major speech at
two one toaster in particular okay you
guys this is the craziest story I've
ever heard in my life so and if you were
a toaster who works at Yellowstone yo
smite Yosemite Oh somebody obviously but
a that's what I was getting so confused
because they were talking about Yosemite
in the records in California I'm like
these morons like Yellowstone is in
Montana's osa might okay by the way did
you say that as a joke no but it is how
it's spelled yeah but like you know I
know it's Yosemite yeah I agree when I
say it was like Mazda Mazda Jon yeah so
we live for dinner after the show with
Nikko I mean it's such a good time you
were just like drinking and she was
heading back on the tour bus and you
know we're good friends so we walked her
back to the tour bus and Luke popped out
like to say hi to us and we were like hi
sir how are you
we just took chatted briefly but he had
a story for us like and as he's telling
the story I'm like why am I being told
why is it for us seem like while I'm
being told this incredibly boring story
about Yosemite but then like this story
everything changed basically Luke was
telling us about like this kind of cool
like celebrity experience he had and he
was like are you just bragging like I
didn't know where the story was going he
was basically telling us a the day off
near California and they were going to
Yosemite and there
this big half that you like go to see
like see the sights like this special
path or something and it was close like
it was gate it was a tree fell oh it
[ __ ] that's when I heard oh I don't
remember I had a couple beers so a tree
fell apparently and Luke's security
guard like went up to go see what was up
like they want it's like but the bus do
they just wanted to go and they can't
hear but they're seeing Luke's security
talk to this woman and the woman and the
the security guard come back and right
we're gonna let you through but honestly
it's only because like I loved Nicole so
much like cuz I'm a toaster and I just
like I love Nicole and like Luke you're
cool too but like Nicole can come up you
know and when he when the word
toaster came out of Luke comes his mouth
like like my world stopped I was like
did you just say toaster like it was the
most shocking thing that's ever happened
like it was the craziest turn of events
like that was a true cliffhanger like
like when then it's like in the movie
when like the end it's not how you think
it's gonna be like that was that story I
was sure I was truly shocked like to me
Luke owns the biggest art in the world
like to this person like didn't give you
[ __ ] about Luke Holmes just heard about
the show scared about the tow student
and Nicole and she is night like I know
so if you work are you're the toaster
who works at us Emily I'm sorry we don't
know your name or anything but like I
just want you to know like we hear you
we see you and we appreciate you yeah
like that's probably the coolest thing
that will ever happen to us yeah and
just say thank you for giving us a
moment thank you so much thank you for
letting them up to Yosemite yeah and the
choices have already given us so much
you know but it's like this is like a
whole other level right and like today
is there a step so before Thanksgiving
so obviously we're gonna talk about what
we're thankful for at the end of the
show but I just don't want to forget to
say like I am thankful for the toaster
who works at Yosemite no no I am I want
to say your name is Laura like that's
just what I want to say and I'm so
[ __ ] thankful for Laura like you have
no idea thank you so much and to all of
our twinners who work at national parks
like right okay and thank you for your
tireless efforts in preserving our
natural parks right we gotta hit up some
our national parks we called it a
natural park I've never been to a
national park and like no shade I like
just don't get it hey you know I
understand why you don't get it because
they're confusing but it's like what
makes a National Park first like a
regular prayer huge Central Park is
pretty no but like they they cross state
lines like they're just huge in
just like these protected parts I don't
really know much more than you but I
know that they're a big deal I get it
again it's like protected land like no
one can ever build a condo truly a
toaster in the wild Thank You Taylor
Rodgers that's funny I'm just yeah well
we'll get to who we're thankful for but
definitely thankful for Laura definitely
thankful for Laura thankful throw your
cemani thankful for all of our national
parks thankful for the national parks we
are going to broke that into the fast
type stories yeah actually today's
stories I just want to preface obviously
you know star-studded but there I saw
some interesting stories because I got
here early because I just had a
torturous morning which is why my bomb
string is almost near its end and I
found some interesting stories that I
thought would be interesting for you
guys either Thanksgiving dinner tables I
know sometimes we have some big stories
just some things to talk about with the
fam we want to leave you as well read
and well learn it and a full and robust
right so like when you're fantastic you
like oh why you single be like do you
know like they're trying this new thing
where they might be able to exceed lives
of gunshot victims like with this new
medical invention oh I thought you were
gonna say like single people like live
longer no no like you just changed the
subject yeah yeah yeah how do you feel
that uber is gonna start recording audio
bombs I heard about that oh my thoughts
so just like some things to talk about
also yeah I'm I'm like really happy for
you because like once the show is over
like you're technically on vacation I
have a show tomorrow which I'm really
excited about New Orleans is gonna be so
late so I can't wait to see you guys
there but you know if you couldn't make
it
got a bunch of more show stickings
available girls on job calm Verona New
York and goal with New Jersey Atlantic
City New Jersey
ramaa Ontario it's gonna be really good
time to really hope you guys can come
through I'm gonna be at Turning Stone
cocina where everyone's planning on
turning them stones y'all do not be y OS
I've gotten confirmation from Turning
Stone that they will provide the stones
and a ceremonial starting in its
ceremonial turning stone after-party in
a ceremonial turning of the sowed yes
and everyone will be able to go up like
turn the stone you should have one stone
that you're meeting green turn it you
know I actually just think I'm going to
walk out with stone my gun like over
like oh my back totally so because I
have to now I'm like a Turning Stone
legend you're Turning Stone [ __ ]
honestly tickets available girls no job
back home in case I didn't say that
enough great stepping you know you'll
probably go to the meet and greet in the
picture sometimes Lighting's graphing
you just need Jack
so head over to Jackie O flow comm for
some premium premium presets I've been
using them I actually paid for them you
did yeah well I texted you like hey how
can I get free ones and you just like
took like one second too long to answer
and I got impatient so I just bought
because you texted me like the morning
when I woke up in a huff in a Joey yeah
the Julian half when you were late late
okay so it's fine I mean I'm happy to
support local businesses I had to change
I support family owned business thank
you I had to change the promo code
they're like free code because I think
Italy got out I think it weeks today
there was a lot of uses I'm sure but I
also like was like probably telling a
lot of people yeah like having a drink
of me like it was my god that's what I'm
into us when we were at a stagecoach I
want to say this guy was wasted in front
of us and he gave us a code to free wild
fox he happened to be like the owner of
wild Fox so he actually gave it to
Lauren Elizabeth but we all heard and we
all use to be all like ran home from
stagecoach in place like crazy orders
and it all ended up coming but they must
have changed a code because I place an
order like six months ago with the code
and it never arrived but that was a good
time like had I known that would have
been the only order I would have ever
gotten like I would have done so much
bigger a metal stuff with it right now
but I actually do enjoy the things that
I got no I like never where actually
when I performed toast on the show and I
wore that tie-dye short set that is from
the free promo code we got from wild
hogs amazing okay well I feel like
without further ado it's time for the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast you know I'm
actually disagree with you on that I
know you just said something kind of
controversial and I'm gonna fight back
saying I actually disagree says it's not
time okay and agree to disagree hear
this because if it was a good civil
discourse if it was time then I wouldn't
be feeling like we're missed I wouldn't
be feeling devastated I wouldn't be
feeling almost heartbroken
oh my god I'm sorry I didn't realize you
had a case of RDH and do you want to ask
me why I'm feeling RDH of course is
everything okay it is it's okay but I
haven't had the time to tell you guys
that Thursday's episode is brought to
you by of course Thursday boots of
course you guys I've been getting so
many questions about the over the knee
boots that I've been wearing because as
a thick legged woman not all of us can
just roll into a store and fit into a
pair of over-the-knee boots like it's so
crazy how we're being marginalized so
I've been wearing a pair of
over-the-knee boots on tour pretty much
to every event and on the toast I wore
them yesterday like the best pair of
boots they're from Thursday boots they
were very reasonably priced they're very
well
they don't get stretchy and like slide
down I hate that it's like once I find a
pair of over-the-knee boots that fit my
big leg stretch them out and they start
sliding down and they're no longer over
the knee they're like a calf boot yes
it's very loud she did so um I got the
pair like two months ago when we first
partnered with Thursday boots and I have
not stopped wearing them since they're
literally the best pair of boots I own
they're so well made and they are so
[ __ ] comfortable agreed I when I
wear my Thursday boots like I wear them
from toast til til dawn right I wore
them I wore them yesterday from toast I
worked all day I didn't go home I had a
doctor's appointment I went to Luke home
saying met Luke Holmes and talked about
the girl from Yosemite and I got home at
11 still wearing the same pair of boots
and like I usually can't be on my feet
for long and I didn't you know it's
really crazy I think that's the most
impressive part about Thursday boots
also the fact that they respect the hell
out of Thursdays right and by the way we
could talk about for hours how Thursdays
are the most underrated day of the week
right cuz like most people think I'm
gonna launch a brand name and after
today like obviously Friday know a lot
more creativity when thinking of a
company called the Thursday boots you
know it's also a good day Tuesday cuz
it's not Monday and it's like the week
it has started but Tuesday's good
because it feels like it has Thursday
times yeah because the lettering you
deserve more comfortable boots without
the high retail markups Thursday boots
is an investment in comfort timeless
styles and staples that will last for
years
Thursday boots believes in year-round
honest prices so while they don't do
sales or discounts they're giving our
listeners free two-day shipping on their
first order and always offer free
returns and exchanges so you have
nothing to lose trying out a few pairs
go to Thursday boots calm / toast and
you can have a beer on your doorstep
before next Thursday that's th urs da y
Bo OTS dot-com / toast for free two-day
shipping returns and exchanges sign on
and look fly yes and feel fly feel flies
hell okay our first story is just like a
really funny weird story and we love a
chance to make fun of vogue yeah cardi B
did her 73 questions which I was in the
middle of watching and it's so good oh I
didn't see um but though did something
really weird when cardi B asked what her
guilty pleasure was she said it was
smelling her own farts okay and they
bleeped out the word fart so does Bo
think Vaart it fart is a curse word wait
that's so weird I just before we even
get into the weirdness in vogue that is
a hilarious
sir smelling right so raw and so honest
and honestly like I stand kardi we now
more than ever but that's really weird
really weird and earlier in the video
she talks about hearing herself on the
radio for the first time she said quote
I was here in New York in the car like
it's me [ __ ] and they didn't bleep
out [ __ ] have they responded or given
a reason why folks communication team
did not immediately respond to page six
Stiles request her comment that is so
[ __ ] weird oh my god and you know
what's so funny I'm glad that like
people are talking about this because
this would have been a thing like we
like would have watched and made me
spoken about on the show like why they
bleep out fart but like no one would
ever really investigate it like good on
page six style for literally like going
to the source and looking for a comment
you know yeah I need to know why I need
to know why to and you know let some
video editor who's like you know like a
freelancer is like shaking
totally also like we need to just like
these Sigma ties farts you know no by
the way I didn't think that they were
stigmatized there's very healthy and
normal I by the way I love a good fart
in the words of Shrek better out than in
I always say so true this is now a good
time to ask and I know the quite the
answer so I think you don't even fart
like but do you fart in front of Zach
not actively but I think like after we
got married like there was one time I
just like blew like there was just like
a little fart
um and I think now that's happened twice
I'm having a deja boo' about it it just
like slips out yeah and it's not been a
big one or like embarrassing by any
means that is so crazy cuz like like the
dead like no no like like a year into
dating bed I just started farting and I
literally never stopped and like I don't
find it weird I'm like I don't think I
could ever be embarrassed but it's like
I don't even fart in front of you know I
know I actually heard you fart once and
it was the craziest thing ever I was
like did you just fart it's not to say
that I don't fart like I fart for sure
and it's definitely good to let to get
them out because like when I first
started dating Zach and I was like
holding in all my farts and not going to
the bathroom like I gave myself serious
stomach problems so like it's she did
she was at the hospital the middle and I
yeah because I had like like gas just
sucked up flying around and by the way
that's apparently a very normal thing
that happens to girls in new
relationships oh my god that's somebody
the doctors like are you in a new
relationship yeah and he's like in the
room
oh oh it's so [ __ ] funny yeah so um
but that's just my personality yeah yeah
no we're we're two totally different
people I just and I wound up working I I
have so much respect for farting and
like people who fart in public like I
never won but I feel I don't fart in
public okay I never want to make it like
anyone else feel shame around here no I
think the only shame that should come
from farting is like what it's smells
putrid it's like what are you eating
like that know this sounds are you sick
I like this town I love partying so much
like I love gas-x
like sometimes I just take it like when
I want to fart you know anything like
there's there's nothing better in this
lifetime then a good old-fashioned heart
yeah I go you know I want to separate
that right so um anyway scardy be farts
too I've ever loved arts everyone fart
what do you think like Lady Gaga's fart
smell like this my like chicken oh my
god I don't I don't think about what
people's farts smell like or sound like
I know I don't know everything
Meaghan Marcos parts ladies sour but
deadly for sure yeah for sure she but
she's you know what she is silent but
deadly like he as a person Megan yeah so
and as a royal like I don't think you
can fart you know it's actually in that
rule book that the Queen hands out did
you see I don't know if it's a story the
priest and of course that story people
get there I was gonna like maybe segue
into it now but I'm not ready to talk
about Jeffrey Epstein like it's too
early Maibaum string is just like - sure
yeah also like I'm almost at the place
like where I'm about to China Jeffrey
Epstein like the memes like it's
becoming too much but we can't trap what
I want I know we can't stop talking
about it because the truth must prevail
and the truth always prevails but I'm
really getting like Tristan Thompson
like ready to church to China I
understand okay
next story really crazy story crazy rich
Asians director responds to Brenda songs
claims that she was quote not Asian
enough to audition I saw this story just
I'd haven't seen that the person
responded but I saw like she was making
news yesterday cuz she was in Teen Vogue
and she made some comments talking about
the movie she said she was a big fan of
the book and asked her managers if she
can set up on it in an audition
she said she quote never got never got
to read for a part in the project quote
their reasoning behind that was they
said it was that my image was basically
not Asian enough in not so many words it
broke my heart
I said this character is in her late in
her late to mid 20s in Asian American
and I can't even audition for it I've
auditioned for a current Caucasian roles
my entire career but this specific role
you're not gonna let me do it you're
going to follow me for having worked my
whole life I was like where do I sit
but that actually [ __ ] sucks yeah and
it reminds me one time I heard Gabrielle
Union doing a talk somewhere and she was
basically talking on that she's really
good friends with Kerry Washington and
when what's that show scandal was being
like audition she said literally every
black woman in Hollywood auditioned
because like there's never been like a
leading role on cable for a black woman
so I kind of understand like why this
[ __ ] sucks for rent a song right and
so she never even got the chance to
audition and the director tweeted back
he wrote questionmark nope I love Brenda
song and that sucks if anything of that
nature was ever communicated it's gross
actually
the fact is obviously I know who she is
and didn't need her to audition I'm a
fan of hers nothing more nothing less
bums me out she thought it was anything
but oh so he's saying he knows who she
was she didn't audition because it
wasn't right no because like he knows
her work like he's familiar with the
part and he said would these words ever
come out of my mouth nope
makes no sense I feel horrible she
thinks this is a reason the fact is I
love Brenda song and I'm a fan I didn't
need her to audition because I already
knew who she was
wait what a droll a strip no I think it
was for the leading role oh I've been
great honestly yeah she's not a star to
me like she's just london tipton she was
too good at that but she was just in
this new movie this horror movie that's
sweeping that flag that was horrible
like Agassi the BuzzFeed article there
was a BuzzFeed article that pointed out
how it the movie like chronologically
and logically did it make sense it was
like 13 ways this movie made up you know
I can't I've never seen it music that
freaked me out yeah like I mean I was
gonna watch I'm gonna finish watching
enough that is a scary movie
I wouldn't that would be considered a
thriller by the way enough was on TV
yesterday and Ben was like it's at the
table immediately just got the rights to
it yeah no because I watched it on E
when like years ago when I was living in
my old apartment I don't know but you
know what I could just keep watching
over and over again what Something
Borrowed oh by the way one of the
greatest romantic comedies of all time I
considered that and raising Helen and a
few other rom-coms to be like elevated
we always talked about how it's like the
other woman the
there woman like there's so many
rom-coms like Heather Ann Heigl worked
overtime you know what's incredible
where I'm come that I haven't thought
I'm glad that it's coming back to me
because it's like one
sorry that's also like morning glory
that I will die on the hill on what's
your number with Anna Faris yep edible
rom-com II can you get the rights to it
so we can enjoy agreed there and I would
say in the remember where they was like
the age of rom-coms and it was like
literally every year like maybe 50
rom-coms I would say there's probably 10
that really likes stand out and I don't
I don't like to call them rom-coms
because it's like it's almost like a
derogatory term now when it doesn't like
make it you don't take it as seriously
but like Something Borrowed raising
Helen when I saw something borrowed for
the first time and I saw it in theaters
I didn't really like it I just I
obviously like wasn't mature enough to
understand the complexity I saw it on
cable like years later and I was like oh
my god how did I not know about this why
aren't people talking about this and
there has been like whispers about a
sequel there's like a huge underground
cult following him this movie it's like
it's not very well known but it's like
if you know something borrowed like you
loved it like nobody nobody doesn't like
it and by the way there's so many good
people in it [ __ ] Kevin from
shameless is Martin what I was saying
whatever like there's so many good
people in it and they've been saying
that there's gonna be a second one like
all the cast is always asked about it
like they've been saying it for a while
because there was a second book oh it's
a book I mean I'll just read it yeah
yeah raising hell in Something Borrowed
okay what's your number other woman
other woman oh I want to say oh no
that's raising Ellen um I don't know
like a Sydney white like there's just
certain hat like House Bunny certain
movies that are saying the holiday no to
me that's just like a cookie cutter like
like white girl rom-com like that nobody
actually likes you know ya know last
holiday that's a [ __ ] that's okay wait
back to redness on cuz the director also
said one of my favorite memories of
making crazy rich Asians was when we
opened the auditions to anyone in the
world with our open call we watched
hundreds and hundreds of videos from
very talented people from all around the
world made us tear up many times this is
so crazy because I actually believe both
of these people a hundred percent but
then the songs not making this up right
but i sad that up until this point she
thought that that's why she didn't get
the role you know and like obvious
she what has been really upset about it
she said she it's like take time off and
like it really just like upset her well
of course like literally this movie
changed this land oh by the Chris rich
Asians is another one of those movies
top channel agree it changed like the
landscape of rom-com cinema in in this
age and it also like was transformative
for Asian American actors so as someone
who's been an Asian American actress and
has never been able to audition for an
actual Asian role like that [ __ ]
sucks
yeah so I get why she took it so hard
and I don't think she's making it up I
didn't choose her for any part yeah I
couldn't see her playing the lead oh I
could she's so cute I just couldn't see
it but also the movie was like so good
and perfect but it's like I really
wouldn't change anything about it I
could see her being like an Aquafina
but Aquafina was so great yeah see
that's the thing I really wouldn't
change anything about right I definitely
would not change Astrid well oh my gosh
she's the most stunning woman in the
world Gemma I'm so obsessed with her -
I'm so such like an elevated actress
like oh my gosh she she dating Robb
Stark because though they were in a
movie or something together
excuse me like I'm not looking to Graham
and like she they're they have like
couple epyck what's his name Richard
Madden Richard Madden and then he also I
just watched Rocket Man on the plane he
plays that mean guy yes he's so mean
he's sewing Rocket Man is such a good
movie so mean to Elton not right no
they're not dating
okay well they like SAG Awards 2019
Jemma Chan runs into Richard Madden okay
well like if you look on Instagram they
they're in a movie together Marvel's the
eternal okay oh my god like play into
yeah
the fandom Richard Madden is so
[ __ ] hot like I die for
Anastasia pthese - I hope they get
together I ship Jemma Chan with whoever
makes her happy because she's such and
by the way I she was like so good at
playing Astrid like I feel like she
really is a stream I agree like in an
unhappy marriage yeah having like having
to hide her shopping
that's so good because like she really
has such great style that guy was like
by the way like of all the storylines
that were in the crazy situations that
one was the one that really like got to
me the most like that like the life that
she gave this guy and then he's [ __ ]
cheating on her like a day right like he
could be you know have his own complex
whatever and their marriage isn't great
but like to cheat on Astrid right in my
face oh no also like don't have a
complex just like be rich you know I
just enjoy it
friends enjoy that apartment okay and
house next story prince andrew has made
the decision to quote step back from
royal duties poyo the luna express um
yesterday Kensington Palace released a
statement saying after he had done that
interview with BBC where whoever by the
way the girl who interviewed him was
very [ __ ] straightforward and I
appreciated her journalistic integrity
they had a chance to watch it yet she
was just like but their picture like she
was just really not letting him slide
yeah and he basically just said like he
they threw a party at their Palace for
glazing and they had no idea who they
were like he was just a plus-one any
time we met him he was close aides plus
one that's what they Prince Andrew like
swore by that he never really knew him
he was just like glazings Fran and lo
Zayn was a friend of the palace and I
haven't attained a fair name of the
palace no one like hey why are you going
on someone's plane if your he's just a
plus-one you know yeah it was just
nothing none of it was adding up and I
guess there was so much backlash after
the BBC interview because he was so like
giving half-truths um that they had to
respond in some way and also his press
secretary quit right oh did she that I
saw him where yeah um the statement said
it has become clear to me over the last
few days that the circumstances relating
to my former association with Jeffrey
Epstein has become a major disruption to
my family's work and the valuable work
going on in the many organizations and
charities that I am proud to support no
please Kumble Bragg you know there flick
out a pedophile but I support charities
right therefore I've asked her Majesty
if I may step back from public duties
for this foreseeable future and she has
given her permission
I continue to unequivocally regret my
ill-judged association with Jeffrey
Epstein his suicide has left many
unanswered questions and many funny
memes on the internet particularly for
his victims and I deeply sympathize with
everyone who has been affected and wants
some form of closure I can only hope
that in time they will be able to
rebuild their lives
of course I'm willing to help any
appropriate law enforcement agency but
their investigations if required well I
saw probably a tweet I don't know where
I saw it someone said that he doesn't
want to perform his royal duties anymore
so that he doesn't have to travel and he
can't get like if he goes to another
country like they can question him about
like tell you I guess if he came to the
u.s. like he could be put on trial right
but he doesn't want to have to try oh
wait that's so interesting
yeah and
that's just speculation but makes to
know it's just like of all the people
who have been publicly tied to Geoffrey
up seen like on Twitter like the they're
journalists who are going through like
years and years worth of paperwork and
like matching photos and there have been
so many celebrities politicians tied to
Geoffrey obscene but no one has been
tied bigger or more or more frequently
or in any other like in the biggest way
more so than Prince Andrew like victims
stating his name like it's not
speculative as it deserves flight
records yeah what do they call the Box
no it's um what the names of look when
you fly private it's like dog no it's
the ledger no manifest
yes Jake thank you Madoff s I mean any
of the words you suggested would suffice
for it but I just I understand no one
has been tied more publicly than Prince
Andrew so this is very necessary like
good good good bye goodnight god Andrew
goodbye
yeah um interesting can't wait to see it
on the crown which is back on Netflix
I'm gonna watch it next week on so did
you see the meme I tagged you in from
Yahoo Jannetty it's a picture of George
Prince little Prince George watching the
crown he's like a man again hey so funny
Garry Jenny is the best [ __ ]
Instagram know I hope that Garry
gianetti's Instagram ends up on the
crown in like five years
oh my god totally well when if you guys
haven't checked out our episode with him
on la week you should definitely watch
it I asked him I was like have you ever
like gotten any sort of inkling that
anyone in the royal family like watches
her Instagram like and I know that their
Royals like every now and then like
we'll get something like the Kardashians
saw this like oh yeah as someone who
works for a nanny like they'll be like
we always get like sometimes I he said
not I'm not a peep not a murmur he has
never heard one thing like not from a
nanny from a staff like nobody know that
but he said that he was that's not like
he's never heard anything from anyone
official but like he has mutual friends
in the circle and like they know to say
though yeah like he I pretty sure that's
what he said that he was at a wedding
and like people were talking about it
people who like our Mutual's
with I think maybe with like the
princesses of Eugenie and Beatrice he
said nobody like no one if it like no he
Kensington themself have not reached out
no of course not but like from a nanning
or something
no I think like maybe friend of Megan
fom fom I would love to be an fom um you
need quiet Priyanka I know she like
really took a step back publicly when
she was like all about it like a year
ago it's exhausting honestly I know I
mean it is truly exhausting just being
like you know trending on Twitter all
the time like yeah everyone's always
coming for me but it's a life I lead I
miss her honestly I miss her too
okay ready for this next story little
I'm not you're not you know I'm not cuz
I'm just I'm not I think we should do an
open fit class before I can officially
be ready I agree I really need the
endorphins
by the way when were on vacation that
actually be a good way to like not
vacation is so dark sometimes like with
the eating like I think open fit might
actually be a group don't actually like
a cute patreon video - yeah I'm so down
open fit takes all the complexity out of
losing weight and getting fit it's a
brand new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your own living room in as
little as 10 minutes a day sculpt your
body within the convenience of your own
home with no eyes on you a gym is so
intimidating so treacherous sometimes I
think the hardest part about working out
is actually getting to the gym like the
traveling the traversing that's where
like they lose me so that's why I really
took to open fit you can workout with
amazing trainers like Andrea Rogers
who's the founder of the worldwide cincy
sensation extend bar or their newest
workout rough around the edges with six
of the most badass stunt women in the
business it's affordable and accessible
are you going on vacation soon and
worried that your hotel won't have a gym
view on your computer web enable TV
tablet smartphone and even Roku some
places only so classes as a package and
often you can't make it to every class
but open fit is bring in the class to
you you get what you put in you can see
results within the first 30 days do you
want to just increase your energy put a
pep in your step and overall feel better
inside do you want to lose weight and
keep it off lose up to 15 pounds in the
first in the first 30 days just the
right way open fit has changed the way
that we workout and texting our code
toast to 30 30 30 you can join us on our
fitness journey personalized just for
you right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge our listeners we got a special
extended 30-day free trial membership to
open fit when you text toast to 30 30 30
you'll get full access to open fit all
the workouts in nutritional information
totally free again text toast to 30 30
30 that's TOA st to 300 300
300 standard message and data rates they
may apply they may sign on look amazing
we achieve a breaking news story before
we get to the rest of the stories so I'm
not breaking um the country star Sam
hunt has been arrested for a DUI in East
Nashville what yeah
mug shot and all OH smiling their mug
shots like me I can't
the story is crazy I need to post them
on our Instagram okay but can you also
listen a hundred percent country singer
Sam hunt was arrested early Thursday
morning after driving the wrong way down
in East Nashville Road while drunk a
police report alleges the 34 year old
was booked into the Metro Jail around
6:30 a.m. on charges of driving under
the influence and having an open
container
Oh according to an arrest warrant police
were notified early Thursday morning
that a driver was traveling south in the
northbound lanes of Ellington Parkway oh
my god when drivers responded to the
area they said they located the vehicle
going the wrong way the driver was also
reportedly swerving in and out of his
Lane um pleats said the driver
identified a Sam hunt smelled of alcohol
and had bloodshot eyes there were also
two empty beers next to him wait am his
blood alcohol level was 0.173
that's more than double the legal limit
point oh eight yeah oh my god I'm shook
that's not good that is not good there's
been something going on with him he was
released from jail around 9:00 a.m. on a
$2,500 bond so 9:00 a.m. central that's
10:00 a.m. here so an hour ago a court
date has been set for January 17th 2020
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
Samuel is such a weird guy like he
became star he disappeared never
released another song again randomly
headline stagecoach like with no name
music and honestly was not a very good
performance and then gets arrested for
DUI like so weird when he's just like
this small town like this is just
doesn't match up with his image you know
um yeah he needs to like go back to his
roots like go back to Montebello like
you know take some time you know I feel
like he's going through nuts - take your
time
he really does I feel as though we
there's been weird vibes emanating from
the hunt camp country music fans like
know that there's something like weird
going on like just the trajectory of his
career was so fast like so ideal and you
don't just like stop working stop
writing music stop doing shows like at
the peak of your career so we took a lot
of time off got married and
kind of blamed like his one or two year
hiatus on the fact that he got married
which I don't really get but it's okay
if that was the case right but this just
is now making me think like the
weirdness that I felt like was
definitely substantiated yeah also he
looks drunk in the photo no one is
smiling none he doesn't even look like
he's like he looks drunk like an only a
drunk person would smile like smirk like
that in a mug shot like I'm right oh my
god I'm a [ __ ] so glad he didn't
hurt anyone oh my god totally driving on
the wrong side of the road it's the most
dangerous thing you could do yeah so
like get your [ __ ] together I will never
understand people who drunk drink and
drive like I understand people who drink
and I understand people who drive but I
do not understand people who drink and
drive like especially in this day and
age okay like 15 years ago like you want
to say you needed to get home okay that
might be something I would buy but like
in the age of uber like [ __ ] you have
no [ __ ] excuse and the age of
left you haven't no [ __ ] excuse
in the age of Juna which just went out
of business the other day breaking news
I know like it's only a thing in New
York I think that app was in a jiff I
get via like are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah also in the age of being a
celebrity hire car and driver oh oh
sorry an agent being rich right get a
[ __ ] driver okay yeah this is
this is not good no no bueno I mean gee
nobody was hurt team of the bucket and G
right so this is a good transition into
our next story about uber Oh
uber will begin audio recording rides as
a safety measure I'm feeling mixed about
this actually next I know how I feel
uber will launch a feature to audio
record rides in the US as a way to
ensure passenger and driver safety
according to company communications
access by The Washington Post and
confirmed by uber itself the company
says it plans to test the feature in
Mexico and Brazil next month before
deciding when to bring it to the US
drivers can set up the feature to
automatically record all rides while
passengers will have to activate the
feature through the app safety toolkit
before getting into a car it's not clear
whether they'll have to enable the
feature before each and every ride
either way riders and passengers won't
be notified when recording starts uber
says they'll get a general warning when
the feature becomes available as well as
prompts asking them to grant the app a
microphone okay so it's only it's an
option um it's an option for passengers
to record but other Ivor's will be
recording I don't know I feel weird
about this like I hadn't
perience when I was in LA a few weeks
ago that really annoyed me
me and Lauren Elizabeth were just we
were so drunk and we got into an uber
and went home and the next morning I got
a 250 dollar charge from the uber and
I'm like literally Lauren plugged in her
arc scored and was playing sad music
Anna I fell asleep like I don't know
what we could have done and they're
sending me pictures of all this liquid
spilt out all over I'm like we don't
even have a drink like we had nothing
with us like I'm telling you there's no
way that this charge could have been
made that's no way this mess could have
been me and like I feel bad that there
was a mess in this carb like we didn't
have a bottle of water we didn't have a
drink like there's literally no
[ __ ] way so I'm like if there
was only some proof you know then maybe
that would have helped so in that
situation I'm like you know what I wish
I had a recording of some side yeah an
audio but like you know there's certain
situations where I could see that it
would be helpful but like the invasion
of privacy like I do all my business
calls in ubers like you so much
confidential information I was giving my
credit card information to you but it's
like no-one's record the drivers not
recording it so I unless he has a great
memory like he's not gonna remember my
joke to me like the potential dangers of
this heavily outweigh like me getting my
$250 back totally overall I'm not here
for this like I am here for uber in like
installing safety initiatives like the
panic button like that should have been
there from the second there are too many
times has someone be picked up an uber
and been kidnapped and murdered like for
me I feel as though this like some ubers
have video cameras on them which is like
I think great I don't think they capture
sound cabs have that too
but this feels like it will it's really
helps for like petty crimes because if
something Crazy's goin down like you
having the audio recording is not gonna
help if someone ends up dead like uh but
when you know you can dispute a $250
charge or someone was saying like my
uber driver like threw my luggage out
into the street like this would have
really helped but it's like what is that
would you rather have all your
conversations recorded in an uber like
forever and you don't know where they're
going and who's listening to them or
okay your luggage ended up in the street
one time ya know to me like this is too
weird I don't like it like this actually
might be something that puts me over the
edge might be a deal-breaker for me me
too and I'm I've been Hoover's number
one customer since I was in the 11th
grade like I've been a VIP since 11th
grade and this actually might might turn
me off
also there [ __ ] or maybe there's a
future even though this is like kind of
black Mara where it's like if you're
below a certain rating maybe you get
record that it's so much better like
them or like judge like no but if it's
measuring
it's an option like I would like some
people might feel really safe having
this and they might really like it and
that's on them then that's fine but I
don't want to be recorded without my
consent
like every no but now signing up for an
uber you're consenting right I don't
know I'm really not here for it I'm
really not here for this whatsoever
right and I think I don't think it
solves that many problems honestly no it
doesn't I don't know how many crimes can
be solved with audio like I watch Law &
Order evil and crimes like if someone
said something rumble the most yeah I
don't know I feel a little like the
audio wouldn't have solved your liquid
problem I could have spilling an
inherent totally I don't know I think a
panic button
I think these drastic measures should be
installed for like the most serious of
situations right like these types of
initiatives like their head is in the
right spot but this is no bueno at all
mm-hmm no I'm not into it I'm not into
it either I hope that I don't know how
other people feel about this because i
just saw the story this morning but like
I hope we all agree and like maybe they
won't do this but this is deafening Depp
definitely really good fodder for
Thanksgiving table oh yes
and so is this next story which I just
found so interesting from a source I've
never said him before the news scientist
is it legit I think so I saw in my
newsletter okay exclusive humans placed
in suspended animation for the first
time I know that doesn't mean anything
to you I'm gonna break it down to you
the way my newsletter did okay doctors
at the University of Maryland's medical
medical schools say they have reached a
milestone in trauma surgery putting
human patients in quote suspended
animation so that they have more time to
operate the process involves draining
the patient of nearly all their blood
and replacing it with an ice cold saline
solution what am i but like when these
just got ya that stops most brain
activity meaning the patient is
effectively dead while the surgeons then
have two hours to operate after that the
body is warmed back up restarting the
heart if trials continue to go well the
breakthrough could have huge
implications for people who come to the
ER with life with life-threatening
trauma injuries like gunshots oh I mean
I guess okay so with people who had
these sorts of getting a nose job like
this is someone elseís for people who
come into the ER and like have a 5%
chance of survival because they're like
losing so much blood they have you know
stabbed gunshots
and it's like whoa this is extra Marini
on someone you need time and yeah these
new trees you only have it like a few
minutes
wait this is legit like the Kingsmen
like when someone gets shot they put
that thing in their brain that's so
crazy oh my god that life imitating art
at first I was really not here for this
like just like figure out how to get
this heart surgery done like if it's not
time sensitive I don't understand it but
now now I guess for cases that are time
sensitive and it they're testing it on
people where basically I'm not sure how
it works because you can't opt-in when
you're like dying on the table but
they're only doing it on people who
would be dead otherwise right you might
have to get like consent of a family
member next of kin yeah well so the
trial is next of kin like are you my
next of kin of been both wait the trial
was given the go-ahead by the US FDA the
FDA made it exempt from meeting patient
consent as the participants injuries are
likely to be fatal no alternative
treatment the team had discussions with
the local community and placed ads and
newspapers describing the trial pointing
people to a website where they can opt
out so right now everyone like if it's a
hospital a certain community it's like
people can opt out and if they become in
that situation they can like it'll show
that they didn't want it would you opt
in I would opt in opt out no I would opt
in I would opt in this sounds incredible
you know it's like I'm gonna die like
what's one last shot you know right of
like modern medicine yeah I trust modern
medicine me too well I mean it's not
like a foolproof they're still doing
trials um they're gonna compare like ten
people um and ten people who have like
the same sort of injury how do you do a
trial you shoot someone you know know
when people are coming into the ER but
they have to opt in no they they can't
opt in because they're almost dead and
you can't like sign like no they have to
have already opted a you have to already
have opted out in the community so say
it's like say this was happening in New
York City it's too big of a city but
they told all the residents of New York
City like from now like there is
something going on at one of the local
hospitals and if you come in with a
fatal wound like you might wind up being
a trial for this surgery if you don't
want to be that person in that case
scenario opt out god I got it so it's
probably to see them a long time to get
the trial because they
to have someone who gets the injury who
comes in and who opted it yeah into the
sealant and someone who did and they
didn't hide it oh they don't have top in
they just can't have opted out yeah
that's confusing okay yeah got it so I
think this could be this could be huge
for modern medicine yeah that's crazy
crazy right those that it's an
interesting story an interesting factoid
um I wanted you a little you know tie
this up with a ribbon talk about what
we're thankful for
but before I do this episode is brought
to you by books I love I know it's a
brand new sponsor I borrowed set Jackie
got the most beautiful bouquet of
flowers for her birthday um and it was
just such a nice gesture there's
something about flowers that's just like
more elevated like then than any other
gift like really makes you feel seen and
special you know we get it ordering
online flowers sucks it's very expensive
you get sad looking flowers that die in
two days hard pass but the bucks is a
total GameChanger
pronounced Fuchs that's short for
bouquets obviously they're sustainably
grown and cut fresh from the world's
finest eco-friendly farms even farms on
the side of volcanoes their source
directly so your flowers stay fresher
longer Jackie got a bouquet for her
birthday yeah I got two bouquets from
bucks and they were so cute they came in
like such nice easy to unpack flowers
with the water spilling like I can't
nuts and I just I loved I loved getting
flowers but I love the getting easy to
assemble flowers it is an awesome gift
it's perfect for birthdays anniversaries
or just because if you're going to
someone's house for Thanksgiving you
want to send them some flowers
um you they offer customizable
subscription services so the flowers
come from eco-friendly farms who pay
workers higher on average and have high
standards for quality and freshness
bouquets are effortlessly styled that
are effortless ly styled perfectly grace
any space you'll find a thoughtful
collection of the freshest flowers
plants succulents wreaths and gifts
there are real flowers that help create
real connections for the folks who want
to have a friendlier addition to their
home the books company's real fresh
wreaths are the answer they're grounded
in transparencies responsibility and
simplicity the books company creates a
genuine moment of emotional connection
for their buck spam and builds
meaningful relationships with
like-minded farmers and florists who
they empower to thrive and eliminate
unnecessary waste along the way there's
no better way to give thanks than with
books you can get 25 percent off your
order from the books company with the
code
toast you know good things come in
flower packages celebrate life's moments
with farm-fresh boots and to get 25% off
your first Luke order go to be o uq
s.com / toasts to get 25% off your first
order with code toast again
that's B oh you cute s.com / toast to
get 25% off your first order with code
toast okay hang on like be good friend
yes I don't o be an [ __ ]
yeah umm it's Thanksgiving it's been an
entire year so much has happened so much
has happened ever since Thanksgiving you
got married
yes Olivia got married yes DJ tea
sweeping the nation gjz sweeping the
nation Theo just continue to evolve and
grow into such a special person he's
like such a better person I didn't know
was possible but he's such a better
person than he was this time last year
and he's really like a reading me
emotionally these days like really
knowing when and how I need him yeah he
listens to your body he does when I
sometimes I can't even listen to my own
he doesn't listen to his own that no
that's for damn sure
I'm just how much has happened let's
let's do a little game let's do a
highlight of the year ooh
I mean we're gonna do this again like
cuz I don't know why I keep feeling like
this break like we're coming back in
2020 like I keep forgetting that there's
a whole nother month but it's like feels
like it's the end of the year to me I
know it's so sad
um highlight of the year I mean
obviously I'm getting married but um I
just feel like it's been a great year
you know like we launched Shannon with
lunch TNN toast is rocking toast is
rocking the toasters are rockin they are
bigger and better than ever
and they're nice yeah we got the
snatchler we got mood we got date night
we got this we have more shows coming
and it's just like it's an exciting time
to be toaster and it's exciting time to
be head toast it is such an exciting
time to be a head toast even though head
toast really did you know die really
soon after she was born she really did
justice for her um but I'm thankful I'm
thankful for the family you know our
health our health like I would knock on
wood and then thankful for the toasters
really just like I'm really thankful for
the Seanie vibes that are emanating here
and and the scene you guys were
receiving back and I feel like I'm
really thankful that like our job is
like I know it sounds silly but it's
like a
creating and spreading steamy vibes
because at the end of the day like city
vibes is just positivity and happiness
and joy and the amount of messages that
we get like just about how the show but
it's like it's just it's so silly what
we do here is not that serious like
we're not curing cancer like we're not
you know freezing people's bodies and
putting ice in there but in their veins
so they don't we have two hours to
operate important surgery right saving
surgery by no means are we doing that
and I'm not trying to make a mountain
out of a molehill but like there is
something really meaningful about just
like making people happy and I feel
really good like when I go to bed and
it's so crazy cause like when I read the
things people say about us on Twitter
it's like we're evil like we are evil
racist and it's like so crazy and they
start telling me things about me and
they're speaking with such certainty I'm
like how do you know like like yeah
speaking on name as such certainty I'm
like you don't even know me like you're
crazy
um when at the end of the day like this
platform has simply meant to make people
happy to spread joy and I feel like this
year we did just that and I feel really
proud of that and very grateful for
there are people who want to consume it
yeah me too and it's just nice to be
part of everyone's day yeah and live out
our dream my dream is being a morning
show host and look at me look at me now
hosting a morning show remember when
that rap was like so I were in it like
they could wrap it and that girl Carmen
wrapped it look at me now so if it said
it was like the fastest rap ever and
like all the kids like I could do it you
know
remember that time in pop culture
speaking of rappers like we're on such
like we're in such a great place right
now but um the post Malone of it all
he's real own gate so you posted a photo
that was a photo I knew about I I know
you went to that festival and you met
him and then I think I didn't mean I was
invited to that festival by him and then
I think you went out to Tao that night
that was different that was like you're
after right and like I don't have my
phone from five years ago like and you
really want me to go find my iphone five
four pictures of me and post Milan
that's how I will but I just have that
picture suffice because like look that's
the picture I wouldn't if you were just
talking about that I wouldn't have
challenged you but you said you guys are
friends hadn't you hung out for time
we've definitely hung out multiple times
what's multiple I want to say four by
like you're holding me to that ever
maybe it was five I don't know but I
just feel that picture that picture
really proves like I'm not [ __ ] lying
no there's nothing that would be a loser
a thing for me to lie about like I have
many moments with puss Malone I have had
four or five phones in the last few
years like sorry I don't keep every
memento I don't scrapbook everything but
you know what
just take that I don't remember many
things and I remember that
so like why would I lie about that no
really why would I lie about that if
you're lying you're doing your face for
you why don't you look up no matter I'm
not lying you are lying
wait no I'm seriously not lying you've
hung out with it's right there you think
I'm lying
yeah then used to be very good friends
with his um manager
okay maybe Ben has the pictures no by
the way I actually went on Ben's phone
today just like just to satiate you
because you're a [ __ ] psycho I went
on Ben's phone to try and find it
couldn't find it like I can't find the
pictures that doesn't mean I'm lying and
I'm not lying w-what your thing for me
to lie about it's like weird think you
think I'm a liar like that's what you
think I mean I think you have said up
and down that you're a liar
no huh what am I said of a letter you
said that you lie about everything what
did I say that in your show but she
doesn't joke oh yeah I'm now being held
to what I say my con is just what are
you the New York Times oh my god I'm not
[ __ ] lying you guys I'm not okay I'm
not lying maybe a weird things are we
the lie about like I'm not even fan of
post alone now I'm not like trying to
prove anything I'm just saying like I
was like everyone loves to us alone now
but like my picture something where
before you even had face tattoo it's
like I'm an OG puss alone white I wish I
were with him pictures your picture
multiple photos okay yep very cool Jill
sees the disease you guys so is lying I
hope you hope you get well soon says
okay um anyways that's our show for till
Thanksgiving I hope you guys have a
great holiday it's the best time of the
year it is oh my god
New York is alive Sunfire yeah and Lea
Michele just weeks from you released her
music video for Christmas in New York
it's so [ __ ] cute it looks like a bed
Del's commercial like it's Christmas SID
no yeah I mean the sound the song
doesn't sound anything like that but
it's like let them know it's Christmas
in New York that's how it sounds sorry
it's such a key music Nadezhda burn like
a big red ball around she's in a snow
globe it's so cute like that is what I
want Christmas to look like forever you
know yeah leave oh I can't wait to write
to the video yes well speaking of
Christmas music we have our holiday
episode of toast radio coming at you
this month on patreon , special morning
toast we'll be sharing our favorite
holiday tunes I'm so excited to record
this episode me too I love to host radio
it's such a good time makes me feel like
Bobby Bo he's such a great idea like
props to the person who came up with it
you oh my god
I thought you were gonna you were
talking by yourself like this [ __ ] is
really trying me today just really my
frickin driving they don't call me a
liar
taking my idea one of the best ideas
you've ever had it's the only good idea
I've ever had that true you did so Oh No
Vienna an Instagram oh do you think that
was a good idea yes I'm loving it okay I
have very few good ideas you guys but
when I do like being friends with post
Milan I know I know that it's right okay
we're just gonna agree to disagree on
that one
no I will not I will not just take this
lying down like your spread rising boss
you're spreading libel about me you're
libelous scandalous salaciousness
calling me a liar I'm not mother
freaking liar Camille okay I'm not I
gotta get bet on here he lived in your
liar than you know he lived it with me
we're not lying okay and I'm not worried
about you calling that miss you guys I
actually have a plan to get to the
bottom of this okay but stop bugging
calling me a liar I'm sorry guys look
I'm just gonna call you something that
you're not okay can I say like this is a
lie this one what's a lot you're over
Tyler like this you're I'm out this okay
but like it's really like upsetting me
that you don't trust me like I'm not by
you I do trust you so why are you saying
that I'm lying why would I lie because I
don't think you're lying I think you're
joking I'm not [ __ ] joking now I'm
too funny it's a curse I'm not [ __ ]
lying you guys I'm dead mother wasn't
serious oh my god this is so frustrating
I feel like this is a witch hunt Salem
witch trials I'm not a witch and I'm not
a [ __ ] liar
okay Camille okay oh my god so
frustrating I'm out here just like
fighting for my life huh what are we
saying
Oh toaster I do we have it memorized so
two more picture and episodes no toast
Radio plan anymore yeah yeah so it's
gonna be great my patreon special
morning toast and next week if you're
working on you're missing the toast just
head there and there's so much condom
for you also next week we will be
getting involved in Black Friday
who's that funny sounds spooky but it's
not a Thanksgiving no it does sound what
it sounds like is there a goblin yeah
I'm so stay tuned on details for our
sale
shot morning Transcom obviously tickets
available girls no junk comm presets
available Jackie Oh Flo calm that's all
the websites we have have a great
holiday of
we'll see you will see never the Monday
after Thanksgiving weekend
you